so
one of the reasons i wanted to talk to
you is you
happen to be one of at least in my view
one of the most credible witnesses
in history of uh somebody who's uh
witnessed a ufo literally an identified
flying object
and not only witnessed but
got to how do you put it like chase it
essentially
chased it so let me just lay out
i think it's easier than you telling the
story maybe
me and my dumb simpleton waist trying to
explain the stories i understand it and
then maybe you can correct me
so on november
10 2004 the
uss princeton which is one of the uh the
carriers that's a cruiser
it's a it's a cruiser it's a cruiser so
you can't land on a uh
no helicopter has a helicopter pad on
the back gotcha and it has weapons on it
okay goddamn it shoots the missiles up
but it has a nice radar just an
incredible spy one system
phased array four panels so looks in
quadrants
perfect so they they started noticing on
november 10th
that there is a few objects flying
around at 28 000 feet
with speed of uh with what's i guess is
considered a low speed of 120 miles an
hour
don't know what that in knots but uh on
the coast of california
so and they kept detecting these objects
for just about a week
then comes in like your
part of the story which is on november
14th
from the i guess it's from the uss
nimitz
i you flew and witnessed
a 40-foot long white tic-tac-shaped
object with no wings flying in ways
you've never thought possible
and in some interview somewhere you said
i think it was not from this world
so there's a mysterious aspect to this
object this entire situation
uh there's videos involved the
video of a flare forward
looking infrared receiver receiver
there's also visible light so you can
switch
tv mode as a tv mode so that gives you
visible light and then it has a ir mode
and uh chad underwood recorded that
video
so and those are the videos that were
released by the pentagon later
one of the three videos the two other
videos
go fast and gimble were recorded in 2000
something 14-15 on
east coast of the united states they had
different kinds of objects but they were
weird in the same kind of way
in terms of at least the videos and the
experiences that people have described
or similar in in the degree of weirdness
but the difference is is
actually on the the east coast of 2014
case
very few people have spoken about it and
even in your situation
very few people have spoken about it so
there's a mystery to it
but it's in some sense this is a quite
simple story
without much resolution to the mystery
and it's fascinating and there's
a lot of opinions there's division of
opinions
because uh it's a mysterious i mean it
truly is a ufo
in the sense that uh you ap
uh what is it i i unidentified
phenomena so can you
maybe correct me on any of the things
i've gotten wrong elaborate on some key
things and describe that experience in
general so here's what i know so yeah
we went out on our mission to go
train and they canceled the mission
and they set us down there's all kinds
of rumors out here there's all kinds of
after this has come out so originally it
was the four of us
there's two jets two people in each jet
their f-18s
okay there is no video from
our event it was all four sets of
eyeballs staring at this thing and then
when we came back and told it
when chad and his pilot took off that's
when chad got the video of it
and we're like that's it that's exactly
that's it and um
so when you say eyeballs you mean
literally your eyes are seeing a thing
yep so so as we're flying out we get we
get vectored they come up and tell us
hey we're gonna cancel training this is
a uss princeton so this is the siege's
cruiser
so we're talking to one controller um
who is like hey sir first you ask what
ordinance we have on board and i laugh
because we don't carry live ordinance in
training typically because batch
stuff happens usually someone forgets to
put a switch on and then the missile
comes off and hits a good airplane and
it's not good so we had what's called a
catim nine which is really just a blue
tube with the
aim nine seeker on the front of it which
is an ir missile
uh so there's only two ways to get it
off you can beat it off the sledgehammer
you can take this thing and so you put a
wrench in and it unlocks the lugs and
pulls the lugs back in that hold it on
when it really fires the impulse from
the engine actually throws the lugs
forward and breaks that release and it
comes off down the rail
that's how it works so they said hey
well
we have real world tasking so as we're
going out
my wingmen the other pilot uh she
maneuvers the airplane to the left-hand
side
of me so she's kind of stepped up like
this and i'll use your mic box
to start so as we're going out they're
calling ranges they're called bra calls
bearing range in altitude
and they're telling us hey it's at 40
miles or 50 miles and 40 miles and 30
miles so they're saying
hey 270 30 20 000. that's all i say
so we got our radars we had we had
mechanically scanned radars at the time
apg-73 good piece of gear
apg-79 new one's way better but anyway
and i apologize if i interrupt the story
hopefully it's useful but they're
telling you a location of a thing that
you should look at
yep they're telling us they have a
contact on their radar they don't know
what it is they just have a blip
they have a little blip well they've
been watching these things and what he
told me is
they had been looking at these things as
we're driving i said sir we've been
tracking these things for about two
weeks that's we had been at sea for two
weeks
because it's the first time we've had
plains airborne we want you to go see
what these are
gotcha so they kind of interrupt the
mission to say
check it out so we start driving out
there
and uh as we get down to he's going you
know
20 miles 15 miles 10 miles and then you
get to a point where they call merge
plot which means we are inside of the
resolution cell of the radar because
radars don't see
everything they're so they have a range
and they have an azimuth resolution
right so and it's basically think of a
little cube so they can
and the whole sky is made of all these
little cubes and they're looking so if
you're inside a cube with something and
you're both inside the same little cube
then the radar can only see one thing
does that make sense yeah so they call
merge plot when we say merge plot to us
it means he's right around something's
around you get your head out so we're
not looking at radar scopes anymore and
the wizards the wizards can look but
everyone it's heads out
when they say merge plot you're done
looking at your displays inside you're
doing this and you're trying to find it
so as we look out to the right and you
look high and low because he could be
anywhere
from the surface all the way up now keep
in mind the ship is like probably 60
miles away so they can't see
the surface and you can do your standard
radar horizon calculation and go hey
it's the
the thing is 40 feet off the water the
panel can he really see
you know there are radars that can see
around the curve but let's just say that
it can't at this time so you go
is it you know where's it at so as we're
looking around
we see now this is a it's a clear day
there's
no clouds and there's no white caps
it's just a calm it's actually a perfect
day if you owned a sailboat
it was that five to ten knots of wind
and you just want to kind of go out
there and you're not going to get beat
up and have white water coming
is the it was the perfect date on a
sailboat how many miles out do you see
like
seven like you see just it's a clear day
that's 50 it's unrestricted visibility
you can see literally all the way to the
horizon it's just
clear it's nothing and we're basically
off the coast if you look at a map and
you go san diego and then inside of
mexico
we're kind of in between that and we're
probably about
by the time this all hits we're price i
don't know
80 100 i don't know but somewhere out
it's pretty far off the coast perfect
visit
from 20 000 feet you'd be amazed you can
do the calculation you can see stuff you
know you'll see land 50 miles away
you can see you know and when you're
looking at a continent it's really easy
to see you're not looking at an island i
mean you're looking at mexico
and you can see on the white gaps in the
water if there's any oh yeah they're
easy
yeah for us we look at it because we
know if it's natural wind or
so if it's a really white cap windy day
then the ships just kind of barely be
moving when we land on it it makes it
actually easier
if the ship has to move where it's got a
big weight because it has to make its
own wind when we land which is the day
that it was this day
you go oh okay and it creates what's
called we call the verbal but when the
air flows across the flight deck it
drops behind the ship
you know and then it kicks back up so
when you're coming board to land it's
going to make you go up a little bit and
then you're going to fall and you got to
con you got to anticipate that to stand
glide soap so
we're pretty we're pretty conscious of
what's going on out there with the waves
in the wind
so we look there's no waves there's no
wind there's no white caps
and we look down and we see white water
so if you put a if you put a piece of
land a sea mount below the surface like
you know even 20 feet below the surface
that's big enough as the waves come in
you know waves have height and length
when they come in that's what happens on
the shore
when a wave comes in it hits and then it
starts to collapse and it pushes the
wave height up because
it can't go anymore and then it breaks
the topic and that's where you get the
white
so what happens is at c when you get a
sea mount you'll see stuff come in the
wave will crash and you'll get white
water
you can go out when it's high tide in
any one of the coasts you can go out
here off of boston and go hey at low
tide i can see those rocks and at high
tide i can't see the rocks are covered
but there will be white water around
those rocks you'll be able to tell
there's something underneath the surface
does that make sense yep
so that's what it was we see we don't
see an object because there's all kinds
of oh they saw this
they saw another craft below the way we
didn't see anything below the water
we just saw white water but the white
water and i like to shape it you can say
it was across i say it's about the size
of a 737 so it looks like if you took a
737
put it about 15 20 feet below the water
so the waves breaking over the top and
you're going to get white water where
the plane is at you'd see
this this kind of shape so it looks like
a cross
so as we're looking down off the right
side the back seater in the other
airplane jim
says this is that talking in parcels
again he says hey skipper do you and
that's about what he gets out of his
mouth and i go
what the hell is that in a nice do you
see that essentially
so we see the white water and that's
what draws our eyes down or otherwise
we'd have never seen it
so we see this i would love to see the
look on your face when you see that
and then we see this little white tic
tac because we're about 20 000 feet
above it and it's doing it's going
basically north south and then east west
north and so
it's abrupt it's very abrupt so it's not
uh
like a helicopter if a helicopter is
going sideways and it goes once
it's going sideways left and it goes
right what it'll do is it'll go it's got
a speed it slows down because there's
inertia
yeah and it stops and then it goes back
the other way this thing's not it's like
left right left right with no so moving
in ways that doesn't
doesn't feel intuitive to you at all of
the things you've seen in the past
so as a pilot the first thing you think
is it's a helicopter
right right so you go oh what is because
when we see it's moving we're like oh
helicopter
so the first thing you look for to see
if it's a helicopter when they're doing
that because
usually when they get down there towards
that 50 feet you'll get rotor wash
you see it in the movies when the
helicopter's by the water it kicks the
water comes up besides because the
downdraft
you know like a thunderstorm will do
that it pushes the air down and then it
has to come out the sides
so you see it and you go well there's no
there's no rotor wash what is that thing
so by this time we're driving around so
as we're if we were at the six o'clock
we're driving around towards that nine
o'clock position and
we're just watching this thing and it's
just it's still pointing north-south and
it's going
left-right and it's kind of moving
around the object and if it had if i had
to say it biased itself
it was biased towards the bottom half so
if you've got the east-west and then the
north-south kind of across
it's hanging out on the southern thing
that's hanging out it's just kind of
moving around up down left and it's
crossing over it it's going up it's just
kind of
so now we're like what the hell is that
so then i go
hey i'm gonna go check it out and the
other pilot says
i'm gonna stay up here and i said yeah
stay up high because now we get we get a
different perspective
so she's up here and i'm down here as
i'm descending
she can watch because right now all i'm
watching is the tic tac
she can watch me and the tic tac so she
gets a god's eye view of everything
that's going on which is really
important
you know you can you'll hear people say
it's high cover whatever she's watching
me
which is it's perfect as the story goes
on because it it gives us
two perspectives you know of a
perspective that's about 8 000 feet
above us
when that thing disappears and they
don't you know because if it's just like
oh i lost it
and they go no it's over to the right we
can still see it we all lost it at the
same time
so as we come down we get to about 12
o'clock and i'm descending it's an easy
descent i'm doing about 300 knots
which is a really good airspeed for the
airplane for maneuvering because
i have i have everything available to me
at that speed
so i'm coming down and as i get to 12
o'clock because the tick takes doing
this it literally it's like it be it's
aware of us and it just goes blue
and it kind of points out towards the
west and starts coming up
so now it's obviously knows that we're
there whatever this thing is and knows
over there
so as we drive around it's coming up and
i'm just coming down we're just i'm just
watching it now you remember this whole
thing is like this is like five minutes
this is not like
we saw it it was gone or oh i saw lights
in the sky and they were gone
we watched this thing on a crystal clear
day
with four trained observers watch this
thing fly around so we're like
okay so i get over to the eight o'clock
position and i'm a little i'm a couple
thousand feet above it and it's about so
i'm probably at about 15k i think it is
i think that's my story's about 50. it's
just estimating
so you can see it's just really easy
descent because
so what's 15k fifteen thousand feet i
thought it was eight thousand
uh uh the the other airplane ends up
about so yeah
okay so they're still about twenty
thousand feet so they're alright
and i'm descending they're staying up
there so i'm kind of doing this okay as
they drive around okay
so i'm looking at this thing and it's
about the two o'clock position we're
about the eight o'clock position and i'm
like oh i've got
i've got enough altitudes i'm gonna i'm
gonna cut across the circle and i tell
the guy in my back seat
dude i'm gonna i'm gonna do this he's
like go for it skip because i was a
skipper
so i cut across the bottom so i'm kind
of
almost coming out co-altitude as this
thing's coming i'm gonna meet it
and i'm driving and uh i get to probably
it's i'm probably about a half mile away
which you think well half miles pretty
far half mile in aviation isn't
it's nothing that's i mean you can tell
there's a pilot in an airplane you can
see all kinds of stuff at a half mile
you can see pretty good detail so i'm
like right there
and it's coming across my nose so now
i'm basically pointing back towards e so
i'm cutting across because i'm going to
the three o'clock position it's at two
o'clock and i'm gonna meet it
at three o'clock so as i do this it goes
it
just accelerates and disappears so it's
this happens at around estimating about
twelve thousand feet so they're at
twenty so they've got about eight
000 foot of altitude above us when this
happens and it just
as it crosses our nose it just it
accelerates and literally
in less than you know probably less than
a half second it just goes and it's gone
and so we're like and i the first thing
is dude
do you guys see it the other airplane's
like it's gone we don't we have no idea
where it's at
so we kind of spin around rook i go
let's see what's down here and i turn
around we're looking for the white water
we can't the white water's gone there's
nothing it's literally all blue so now
you go
and i remember telling the guy in my
back seat like a dude i'm
i don't know about you but i'm pretty
weirded out because this is i mean
you know i had at the time like 30 some
hundred hours of flying i'd been doing
it for 18 years
it's nothing like anything you've seen
no no so
as we turn we go well let's just go back
you know because now i got to put on my
real hat which we have to train because
we're getting ready to deploy to you
know overseas
so we got to get our training done so
that's my mindset especially as a ceo
because i get i get it training out of
the flight time because i'm responsible
to do that so
hey let's go back and the the the guy
who's going to be the bad guys is the
ceo of the marine squadron
and uh so cheeks is at the he's
listening to all this happen you know
because he's just like
because he they when he first went out
they were going to do him but the little
hornets the legacy hornets the f-18cs
don't have as much gas as the super
hornets so he had
launched first and they were going to do
him and then when they knew we were off
the deck they just told him hey go to
your cat point down south
and we're going to send we'll pass this
off to
the the super hornets what's the cap
point uh that's where we hold so it's
called a combat air patrol
point so we're just going to hold at one
end he's going to hold at the other end
it's kind of like hey you guys are going
to each think if it's a football field
we're going to sit on one goal line he's
going to sit on the other goal line and
when they say go we're going to run at
each other and
try and do something in the middle of
the field and then go back to our set
reset points okay
so you're talking to him he's he's he's
listening to the he's just listening we
don't talk to him at all he's just
listening he just dials up because they
know that we all know the frequencies so
he's listening to what's going on
because he's like because they cancelled
training so what else is he going to do
he's just going to hang out there and do
circles while he's waiting him and his
wingmen
so they're just they're listening to all
this go on and then at this point you
move on
yeah we come back up to train we go back
as we're flying back
the controller because we're talking to
the the kid on the princeton
the uh the uh they're called os's
they're operation specialists they're
the ones that run the radars
and we're talking to him and he's like
hey sir you're not going to believe this
but that thing is at your cap
it showed back up it just popped up you
know this is like 60 miles away it just
reappears we're like oh okay
so we got the radars out we're looking
for it uh we get out there we never see
it
we never see it again uh we do what we
need to do we come back to the ship
of course now we're like oh this is
gonna be we're you know i told i told
him i go dude you know we're gonna catch
we're gonna catch [ __ ] for this
when we get back to the ship word's
gonna get out and we're just gonna catch
maximum [ __ ] and we did yeah and it's
kind of that joking
you know so the ship plays movies we
have movies on the boat and they do 12
hours of movies so they repeat because
there's a day check and a night check so
the same movies in the morning and night
plays so you never get to ever get to
watch a whole movie on the boat
which drives my wife crazy because i'll
watch stuff on tv that way too i'll be
like oh hey i've seen this and
i'll jump into a movie in the middle and
then i'll pick it up later and i'll see
the beginning and i'll put it all
together
because that's how we have to do it
because we're so busy well the movies
became
and i it was men in black aliens uh
independence day definitely going to
catch some [ __ ]
but let uh let me just ask some dumb
questions so just take him because
whatev whatever the heck you saw
whatever the heck happened
it's you know one of the most
fascinating things um
events in recent history so
whatever it was it's interesting to talk
about it different kinds of angles
there's no good answers but it's
interesting to ask some dumb questions
here
uh so first of all you mentioned so you
saw
at some point xy and then
somebody in the princeton said you're
not going to believe the sir
it's at your cap point that that's a
different place how the heck did it know
what your cap point is
that's a good question and that's the
one if you don't no one you know you
don't
we don't tell it it's we don't broadcast
it we have a waypoint in the system
but i don't know maybe it knew where we
were going because we used the same one
day after day after day
but it it obviously knew but you never
saw it there never saw it there chad
when he took off when he got the video
we landed we told them hey look we just
we just chased this thing they're like
when i go chased it and they're like why
go
dude and i told him i said dude get
video and he goes
so and that's how he is he's like i'm
gonna go and he was he he was determined
he was gonna find this thing so when you
look at his video this is the stuff that
isn't out that they don't see because
not all the all you see is the flare
tape that's the targeting pod the
forward looking infrared receiver
um i'll probably overlay the videos when
he goes out
it's uh you know what he's looking at on
his displays is he has basically two
radar displays up
he has azimuth and range on the right
one and he has azimuth and elevation on
the left one so this is called the as l
display
and this is called this is basically the
ppi which is the
you're at the bottom of it you're at the
bottom of the square it's really taking
this
it's taking a cone because a radar
really looks left and right from a point
and it squares it out so the entire
bottom of the scope that we look at is
us
because they do this they square it off
so so he goes out and when he first sees
it he gets a radar return on it because
when he's not trying to lock it so the
radar's just throwing energy out and
getting it you know it's a doppler radar
so when it's in search mode that's all
it's doing it's going oh i can see you
i can see and it's looking for return so
he gets a return so he wants to see what
it is because all you get is a little
green square unless it builds a track
file on it
but the little green square is just
sitting there it's not moving because
it's
it's sitting in one spot in space he
locks it up when he goes to lock it up
now he's putting a bunch of energy on it
but he's telling the radar stare down
that line of sight and whatever's there
i want you to grab it
and build a track file on it which will
tell us how high it is how fast it is in
the direction that it's going
okay the radar smart enough that when
the signal comes back if it's been
messed with
it will tell you it'll give you
indications that i'm being jammed
so that's all it is is you send the
signal out something it manipulates the
signal either in range and velocity or
whatever and it sends it back
and the radar was smart enough to go
that is not a return that i'm expecting
something's messing with me i'm being
jammed and it shows you and it puts
strobes up it gives these lines on the
radar and it does some
stuff so you can i mean well it does it
goes full into
it it's being jammed at about every mode
you can possibly see because everything
comes up and the the
this aspect gets long it's all kind of i
don't want to get into details but you
can tell it's being jammed
so and as you said on rogan by the way
that jamming is an act of
war active jamming isn't when you
actively jam another platform yes
it's technically an active war feels
like you should be freaking out at this
point
i mean so well he does it and then in
the back seat so they don't have a stick
and throttle they have
their side stick controller so they can
control all the sensors and they can
just toggle around and do stuff so
he can he has the ability to just move
one switch real quick and it will go
from that azimuth elevation on the radar
to the targeting pod
well as soon as he commanded the radar
to look at that target
the targeting pod goes oh what's over
there and it'll stare because it goes
down the line of sight because all the
systems are hooked together
you can decouple them but they're going
to automatically couple up
so when he castles over he it's a switch
looks like a castle situation castle so
when he moves that thing to the left and
he swaps the displays out and he says
instead of looking at the radar i want
to look at the targeting pod
he sees it on the targeting pod because
the targeting pod's already looking
there
and now he's on a passive track because
he's not literally sending any energy
out he's just receiving ir energy from
the tic tac
and then the system itself will track
the pixels
and the contrast differences it depends
on what mode you're in so it says oh and
that's what those little bars you see in
the video where the bars come up
laughter doing some
v vision based tracking that's exactly
what it is
um so that's the video he goes through
changes zooms changes the mode he goes
through all the modes so there's the
narrow
medium and wide so wide is far away
medium and then narrow
and then there's the tv mode and he goes
from ir mode to the tv mode
the cool thing with the tv mode is
narrow ir mode is only medium tv mode so
you can actually get closer with narrow
tv mode it's got a better zoom
capability when you go into tv mode
um so he goes through all those things
that's when you see it going from a
black background to a white background
trying to figure out what the heck is
this well yeah and he wants to get as
much data as he can on it
based on the different modes instead of
just staring at it going what is that
thing yeah
um green so the the video has been out
it actually was on youtube for years and
before the government released it
leaked
the guy that was in my back seat sent me
an email and i had retired
so this is about no because i was
working
i was working down in san diego so this
is about 2008 early 2009
he sends me a link to strangeland.com
which is not suitable for work oh yeah
it's top-notch yeah
and he says hey i can remember the email
hey skip does this look familiar
and i look at i'm like how the hell did
that get on
strangeland.com so the next thing you
know it ends up on
youtube which was cool because you can
send a youtube link to someone
you don't send strangeland.com to
someone because you don't know what
you're gonna get yeah
it's like googling kittens yeah um so
it ends up there somehow so it gets on
youtube which was cool because
i would go out with my friends and we'd
be drinking and they they go dude what's
the coolest thing you ever saw flying
you know it's kind of like you were
asking what it's like and i go
oh dude i chased the ufo and they're
like get out and i'm like no serious so
this is literally how it happened
so i was sitting with my friend matt so
matt and i did our my
he was the guy in my right seat of the
a6 when i did my very first night trap
right and we were friends to this day
right because
when you do stuff like people like that
you know you had to have faith in him he
had to have faith in me
you know it's their they become like
your brother yeah
um and these are guys that literally you
know i don't talk to him on a regular
basis like
chris who works at apple if if chris
called me up
tomorrow and said dude i need help i
need this i'd be like all right let's
figure this out and let's do it because
it's they're like family
you do it and most navy guys we don't
we're not we don't send letters to each
other weekly
you know i have friends that could i
haven't talked to in 10 years if they
showed up on my door
you know pop a bottle of wine grab a
beer shoot the [ __ ] take about first 10
minutes to catch up and then it's
it's like old times and it's it's
amazing how fast this happened so
incredible
so i'm out to dinner with matt um and
i'm telling him this story and he's like
get out of here so he goes back and he
tells our friend paco
paco has uh fightersweep.com it's a blog
site
so paco's obsessed like he is way into
ufos yeah
so paco calls me up he says dude i was
talking to maddie that's what we call
him he goes i was talking to maddie
he goes dude you got to tell me this
story
so i'm like all right so i spend a chunk
of time and so
he calls me one day and i'm like i get a
voicemail
hey give me a call so i call him up and
he answers the phone but i can hear
people in the background and i go hey
dude what's going on he goes hey
hang on i gotta put you on speakerphone
i go what do you put me on speakers you
gotta tell the story i'm having a dinner
party
you gotta tell the story so he's
literally having a dinner party with his
cell phone in the middle of the table as
i tell a tic tac store
so he calls me up again he says hey i
got this blog
and he just writes about fighter stuff
like he wrote about that we call him the
[ __ ] hot break that's a guy that when
you land on a carrier comes
and turns and gets ready to land really
fast like breaks it off right at the
back of the ship
and uh uh one of the guys when we were
junior officers on the uss ranger one of
the apartments the other squadrons guy
nasty
and nasty was notorious for coming in in
the tomcat and cranking off the [ __ ] hot
break
right so he he he literally wrote a
thing about the [ __ ] hot break with
nasty and there's another guy or mav
was our uh one of our landing signals
officers for the air wing
it just it was it's just it's a good
article on how this was and how you know
it kind of forms you in naval aviation
it's kind of becoming a
part of the club so he's like i got to
write about this thing i'm like what do
you guys got to write about i go all
right
i go because at first i would say no i'm
like dude i don't want this out there
just
you haven't really before then talked
about it much
my wife didn't even really know the
whole story what just as a comment is it
just because you caught some
no uh it was just i'll tell you what
three days we we had the incident
for about two days they played the goofy
movies there's a comic on the back of
the air wing schedule
that they would put it was like first
one was a far side and the second one
was
me and the guy in my back seat and it
was men in black but it had our names
you know protecting the world protecting
the nimitz battlegroup type stuff it's
just funny [ __ ] like that
um so to me it wasn't that big of a deal
it was like okay that's weird we're
never going to know what it was
i want to get out because this is
important because there's all kinds of
rumors there's a group of folks
no one ever came out in suits
to talk to us nobody looking like me
no came out no on a uh no no one came
out of the helicopter no one came out on
an airplane
you know you get oh i i was told to turn
over this classified what's funny is all
the cos
and several are still in the navy uh
there's one that is a
he i think he just finished up he was a
captain of an aircraft carrier
you know so he'll end up making admiral
and all that stuff
those guys are all my friends i talk to
them daily just just to clarify so
just for people who don't know there's a
story
that both on the nimitz and the
princeton
folks in a helicopter landed
they showed up they took the data
quote-unquote so
all the sort of recordings associated
with this
incident and they took it and presumably
deleted it
there's a kind of story to that and then
uh from what i've seen you said that you
believe
just like we were talking about offline
that jokes spread faster than uh
or just rumors spread faster than
anything on on these ships
uh that it might have been a joke that
started
and uh well they did so here's here's
the joke yeah so they had come down
right we had the tapes um and they were
chad's tapes
so we use those tapes over and over
again you know they're they're
consumable but remember i have a budget
as a squadron so you have a budget so i
have to buy those tapes i have to
all that stuff that we use i'm
accountable for and the tapes are
actually classified secret because of
the data that's on them
okay so we had the tapes so the the
secure the intelligence guys
the intel officers came down from what's
called civic it's cvic which is carrier
intel center
came down and said hey we need the tapes
these guys are going to come
they're going to come and get them this
is so like i'm like oh whatever you know
so we hand them the tapes and then
someone because i have you know you know
people
shortly after they came and got the
tapes someone came to me and said you
know they're they're messing with you
they're playing a joke
so i said oh let's see how well that
goes because you know
i'm a ceo and they're not and so i went
down to civic
and uh it was a probably he was a
lieutenant or a lieutenant jg so he's
way junior to me
and i said hey uh i want my tapes back
and he looks at me and i go i know you
guys are pulling my leg i know you
there's no one came out
and i go and you have about 30 seconds
to get me my tapes before i start
tearing this place apart
that's literally what i told him and i
said and if your boss has an issue
he can come and see me because it's not
going to go well i said because this is
[ __ ] and i need those tapes
then he literally walked right over to a
filing cabinet opened it up they weren't
a safe he opened up a filing cabinet and
pulled him out and hand them to me
i said and i basically said a few things
to him like don't ever [ __ ] with me
again
and i left i had the tapes so this no
one came out
there's no flying going on when all this
is happening and i took the tapes back
and then i copied the tapes so i took
two brand new eight mil tapes and i
copied
the sections that i want so there's a
rumor too that oh the original flea
video is 10 minutes long and there's
some one of these petty officers saying
i saw it that's total crap the original
video is about a minute 30 seconds long
what you see
on the release video is the entire video
so you have mentioned
uh i apologize if i say stupid things
please correct me but
you you have mentioned that uh like on
rogan i think
that you watched it on you know on a
bigger screen it felt like it was higher
definition
so let me ask the the question
is there a higher definition version do
you think of the
flare video that would give us more
pixels and more information presumably
because of the
um i would doubt it because i don't know
where
the stuff that the government released i
don't know where they got okay so the
stuff that was on strangeland and
youtube
you know someone pulled off of a secret
it looks like a rack
you know there's tape machines in there
and it gets converted to digital and
stored on a hard drive and they pulled
it off that hard drive and they put it
on youtube
um no it's it's just like you know
anytime
even a digital media the more you copy
digital media there's some quality
that gets it degrades so this you don't
know how many times this has been copied
so we were looking
the videos i've seen are right off the
original they're high eight tapes that's
basically pulled off the back of the
display so it's not filmed with cameras
it's literally a digital feed that's
pulled off the back
and put onto a high eight tape that's
how the recorders work now it's actually
digital to digital it's not even on
tapes anymore it's it's a digital
recording system but we were still in
that process of slowing up because
originally we had little cameras here
that shine so if the light hit it would
wash out the displays
so this it's a pretty good feed um when
you put it on so we're instead of
looking at it on your tiny little
computer monitor whatever i'm looking at
it on a
like a 19-inch because it was still
normal tvs back there we had just put
flat screens in the ready room that i
had bought
so we could watch movies so a nice huge
19-inch screen
this is maybe 20. it was a nice wow
that's huge
gigantic um hey i can get for like
50 bucks you can kill like 60 engines
this is 2005. yeah
um so so you look at this big thing and
but you could see so when you get to the
tv mode when i say there's little things
coming out of the bottom of it you could
see those
it was very clear but in terms of the
actual
visual on the tic tac was it did you get
much more information from the hired
from the clear little things out of the
bottom
to the bottom information so when you
see it because he's coming almost
co-altitude with it you can see the
bottom of it looks like little
you know like if you look at a cessna
there's little antennas hanging on the
bottom kind of like that there's two
little things on the bottom
there's nothing on the top there was no
plume no ir no
no visible propulsions even heat
signature
you know it's all that stuff and then
the other thing that people didn't see
is they didn't see the the radar display
uh which that that really raises the
classification level especially to see
what the radar does when it's being
jammed
um you know what i matter of fact when
they did the unofficial official
investigation in about 2000 and
let me think about 2009 um
i got a call on my cell phone from a guy
who government
employee and said hey he told me who he
was he's still in the government
um i'm friends with him and he said hey
we're gonna investigate your tic tac
thing this is literally
five years later yeah five years later
and i said
okay whatever and he did a pretty good
job i caught the unofficial official
report because
um it was really never official
it wasn't but i'll give you the history
of why i say that and why it never came
out in foia requests
so he does the report he sent me the
report and all he said is hey i'm going
to send you this report please don't
distribute this report i said okay
the report is now out because harry reid
got it to george knapp
and they were good enough to redact
there's a few versions of it unredacted
and i'm very protective of the other
people that were
involved in this so jim has talked but
he's off the grid he doesn't talk to
anyone now
the pilot of his airplane she has come
out on unidentified but
they don't release her name although
people are starting to do it and she's
had weird
[ __ ] happen around her house she's got
kids you know so i'm very protective of
her
and i've told people like jeremy and
george if i know that the names ever
came from you i will never talk to you
again about this
and jeremy's been really good about it
and so is george and then but george
george knew who the names were because
he had he got the report from senator
reid
um and then the other crew so the pilot
of the airplane that took
the video that chad was in if you talk
to
that individual they really don't have
the recollection they were just out
flying that day and it wasn't a big deal
um so it's it's you you need to protect
because not everyone wants people
knocking i don't want people knocking on
my door
and you know and there's rumors oh you
talk to everyone i think you're about
the 23rd person that i've talked to
total and that includes uh you know the
newspapers and stuff and i've been
selective because there's so much i mean
if i turn down like
i turn down russian tv uh i can give you
her name when we're done here
she called she not only called me she
called my wife she called my daughter
she called my son and she called my
son-in-law
because they're persistent so i'm i'm
pretty protect
i'm very particular i mean the reason
i'm talking to you is because i knew we
would have a conversation that wasn't
based just on the tic tac and the
incident but we can actually talk about
some of the science and some of the
theoretical to get into to get more
people involved to go
because i think there's you know and
when you talk to
you know lou elizondo or chris mellon
you know the group at ttsa you know that
that whole thing was
that's to the stars uh academy okay
that's the tom delonge group that got
started so
and you go well uh you know because i
think tom has caught a lot of crap for
this but he's actually
when you talk to him he's he's he's very
smart and i asked him how'd you get into
this and he goes oh when i was traveling
around with blink 182
he goes you read a lot of books when
you're laying in a van as you're driving
to your next gig
before you make it big and he goes and
he read he was reading books and he read
one of them on ufos i'm trying to think
the title that's one of the big ones
that's out there
real popular and so he started just he
started asking more and through his
fame with blink 182 in the band he got
more and more connected
you know if you talk to chris mellon who
is an under secretary of defense for
intelligence and he's part of the
melon you know dynasty you know from
carnegie mellon type
very very smart he knows he he he
definitely knows how the government
works because he worked there
and so when i went down to dc to talk to
people
he's one of the first people i'll go to
when i did uh
tucker carlson about a month ago month
and a half ago
um i asked i i he texted me i i texted
him
tom liu to go hey because they were like
you got to do it because i turned to i
turned tucker down a couple times before
and his uh his producer had called me
and i'm like
all right i'll do it because those guys
like you got it you got to do this for
us
you